poland has relied on the US as a partner
ever since it threw off communist rule
bill clinton visited in 1993 george w
bush 10 years later then Barack Obama in
2011 now it's Donald Trump's turn the
United States is seen as the main main
security grant for security and the main
ally when it comes to hard security and
unfortunately we have seen in recent
years
very negative developments in Ukraine
does the need to actually have a very
strong relationship with the with the
United States is very important for her
for them 900 US troops are currently
stationed in Poland Warsaw has been
counting on the US and NATO to protect
Poland against Russia but that's the
tall order
the current president once described
NATO as obsolete
Trump has since rolled back that
comments telling Romania's president he
supports the Alliance's mutual defense
close I'm committing the United States
and have committed but I'm committing
the United States to article 5 and
certainly we are there to protect during
his visit Trump aims to strengthen trust
between Washington and war so but that
might not go as smoothly as he'd like in
war so Trump will sit in on a meeting of
the three seas initiative a coalition of
12
EU member states from Central and
Eastern Europe I think Poland where the
Polish leader would also try to use it
as an as a support for for his
initiative of of the three the three
seas initiatives where he tries to
develop in the way the countries as a
counterweight well both to as a defense
against Russia but also to a
counterweight to Germany
with having Donald Trump as guest of
honor the participants of the three sea
initiative can be sure of international
attention and also for the American
president visiting Poland is a good
choice the country share similar more
conservative values so Trump can expect
less hadwin from there
then from other European countries but
Donald Trump also wants to improve his
image back home the most recent polls
show approval ratings of just 36% it
does want to be seen as a statesman and
meeting and dealing with which other
friendly statesman is is playing into
him into that Trump can expect a warm
reception from Poland's conservative
prime minister Beata she'd wa but he
won't have long to savour it before he
heads to the g20 summit in Hamburg where
the welcome is likely to be far less
friendly